there is never a debate between pure
free speech and pure censorship the
debate is always about what are the
standards going to be what are the
taboos going to be what are we going to
discourage what are we going to censor
in the old Society in the old normal
good Society we would censor obscenity
we would sometimes censor falsehood
today we censor virtue we censure true
statements we censor plain facts about
the world and we encourage obscenity and
falsehood and ugliness and all the rest
does that make a lot of sense I don't
think so there's not going to be any
society that doesn't censor anything so
it's just what what do you value what is
your taboo I for one would prefer to
censor the falsehood and the wickedness
and the ugliness